>>> MOM DAD, GET UP!
>> COME ON YOU GOTTA WAKE UP!
WAKE UP.
>> GET UP.
>> WAKE UP.
♪ CHRISTMAS MORNING
LET'S OPEN UP OUR PRESENTS ♪
♪ WELL, I GOT A NERF GUN ♪
♪ I GOT A HAT ♪
♪ I GOT AN AUTOGRAPHED
BASEBALL BAT ♪
♪ I GOT A TELESCOPE
I GOT A GLOBE
I GOT A WATCH
♪ AND I GOT A ROSE ♪
I GOT HULK HANDS
♪ I GOT A TIE ♪
♪ I GOT A COPY OF
"THE CATCHER IN THE RYE" ♪
♪ I GOT A DRUMSET
I GOT A PHONE
I GOT A PEN
AND I GOT A ROBE ♪
♪ I GOT AN OUTDOOR
PIZZA OVEN ♪
♪ AND I GOT A CAMEO
FROM McLOVIN ♪
♪ I GOT A HOVER BOARD
♪ I GOT A DRONE ♪
♪ I GOT A LAPTOP ♪
♪ I GOT A ROBE ♪
>> THANKS FOR THE ROBE.
IT'S REALLY, REALLY NICE.
I LOVE THIS ROBE, GUYS.
THIS IS GREAT.
♪ I GOT HEADPHONE
I GOT A WIG ♪
♪ WE GOT THE PIANO FROM BIG ♪
♪ I GOT A VINTAGE
PINBALL MACHINE ♪
♪ AND I'M GOING
TO MAKE US BREAKFAST
IN MY BRAND NEW ROBE
WHICH I LOVE SO MUCH ♪
♪ IT'S REALLY SOFT
OH, IT'S ON SALE
I GOT A SWORD ♪
♪ I GOT SHADES
WE GOT PAIRS OF
ROLLER BLADES ♪
♪ I GOT A LEGO
MILLENIUM FALCON
AND I BURNED MY ARM
IN THE OVEN ♪
♪ IT HURTS PRETTY BAD
BUT I DIDN'T EVEN SCREAM
BECAUSE I KEEP THE
PAIN INSIDE OF ME ♪
♪ MORE AND MORE PRESENTS
LET'S OPEN UP
OUR STOCKINGS
MINE HAS A SET OF ♪
♪ TRAVEL GAMES
MINE IS STUFFED
WITH CANDY CANES
MINE HAS A BOTTLE ♪
♪ OF NICE COLOGNE
MINE IS COMPLETELY EMPTY
JUST A BIG FLAT SOCK
WITH NOTHING INSIDE ♪
♪ ONLY HANG IT UP
CAUSE IT LOOKS
KIND OF WEIRD
IF IT'S MISSING IN
OUR PICTURES ♪
♪ HOLD ON NOW ♪
♪ WHAT'S THIS I SEE ♪
♪ A FEW MORE PRESENTS
BENEATH THE TREE
LOOKS LIKE SOMEONE'S
GOT A BIG SURPRISE ♪
♪ OH, YOU GUYS REALLY DIDN'T ♪
♪ NEED TO GET ME --
IT'S PRESENTS
FOR THE DOG ♪
♪ HE GOT A BONE AND
A SQUEAKY TOY
AND PEANUT BUTTER TREATS ♪
♪ CAUSE HE'S A GOOD BOY
SO MANY PRESENTS
BUT HE DESERVED IT ♪
♪ AND HE GOT A ROBE
IT'S CHRISTMAS MORNING
LET'S TAKE A FAMILY PICTURE
I DON'T HAVE ANY MAKEUP ON ♪
♪ I WAS UP UNTIL 4 IN THE --
WHAT A GREAT PICTURE, LET'S
PUT IT ON THE INTERNET ♪
>> YOUR MOM DOES EVERYTHING FOR
YOUR FAMILY.
THIS YEAR, GET HER MORE THAN ONE
PRESENT.
MOMS LIKE STUFF TOO.
>> WHO TOUCHED MY PIANO?
>> IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
[ APPLAUSE ]